relentless push it was remarkable
this may be the most important speech
i've ever made more for how it was
delivered than the sentiment
donald trump does not accept the result
of the 2020 u.s
presidential election but for the man
regarded as the most powerful politician
in the world
no network coverage no packed rally
instead
a 46 minute video on facebook it was a
rehash of conspiracy theories
and evidence already rejected in court
but it boils down to this
donald trump believes there was a
campaign to steal
the election this colossal expansion of
mail-in voting opened the floodgates
to massive fraud almost all of his
claims have been thrown out of court
the judges who've rejected his motions
include those appointed
by donald trump and the president's
comments
coming just 24 hours after his attorney
general confirmed
the department of justice has seen no
evidence of widespread voter fraud
from the podium of the white house
briefing room a few hours earlier
no ringing vote of confidence in william
barr
does he have a faith in attorney general
bill barr does he still have confidence
in billboard
um the president if he has any personnel
announcements will be the first to know
it
the electoral college will meet on
december the 14th the trump campaign
will push ahead with legal action until
then
donald trump says he will accept any
accurate election result
the states have already certified the
results joe biden won
and is the president-elect alan fisher
al-jazeera
at the white house